Cocco God we're gonna talk tennis right
we're gonna talk tennis Coco Gotha is
proving she is unstoppable
the youngest player at the Australian
Open just made it to the fourth round in
her biggest performance yet watch look
at that excitement the 15 year old out
stood defending champ
Naomi Osaka the teenager dominated the
match to beat the third seed 6-2 3-6 to
4 you could see the dismay on Japan's
bases but I love that Koko is you know
tennis stars are very intense she's just
like this is great unbridled enthusiasm
she never leaves that and everybody
cares for her - Naomi's great - 22 she's
phenomenal
gogo can't even drive yet I know
youngest player to knock off a top-five
opponent women's tennis since 1991 yeah
big win big win for you need time Serena
Williams quest for 24th Grand Slam
singles from Gayle okay that is over she
suffered a shocking upset to China's
Wang Chung marking her early exit at
Melbourne Park in 14 years there were
audible gasp from the crowd though after
this moment Rafael Nadal accidentally
hit a forehand right into a ball girl's
head afterward the tennis star rushed to
make sure she was okay and got a little
out on the head little kiss
didn't bill Rafa well done Thank You
Vlad